we've all lost it at one point or
another during an emotional film
sometimes in just about any movie all it
takes is a well time moment or a single
line and bam waterworks
but the scenes in these movies in
particular cranked the sadness up to 11
leaving the audience practically
swimming by the time the credits roll
clear your throat because we're about to
put a lump in it with the most emotional
movies of all time interstellar if
you've caught Christopher Nolan's space
epic interstellar you know what's coming
next this story of headstrong astronaut
Joseph Cooper played by Matthew
McConaughey isn't one you'd anticipate
to have you bawling like a baby but oh
it absolutely does with Earth facing
extinction Cooper and the crew of the
spaceship endurance head out in an
attempt to find a suitable planet to
colonize but after getting stranded on
one planet for decades of relative time
Cooper arrives back on the endurance two
years worth of messages from his
children Murphy and Tom they were just
kids when he left Earth but they're now
adults compound this with McConaughey's
gripping performance and this scene
leaves you decidedly not alright alright
alright guardians of the galaxy for all
its High throttle space action and
hilarious one-liners guardians of the
galaxy still managed to deliver a rich
emotional story and a couple of moments
that just broke the tear Bank completely
one of the most heartfelt parts of the
movie comes right in the opening scene
which sees young Peter quill with his
mother on her deathbed it's bad enough
when Peter refuses to take her hands
seconds before she flatlines but let's
face it we all lost it when Peters
grandfather has to pull him screaming
from the room
[Music]
geez not even five minutes into the
movie and you're already sobbing into
your Milk Duds the Green Mile adapted
from the 1996 Stephen King novel The
Green Mile seems like a dark film on the
surface but what lies below is a web of
relationships it'll tug at your
heartstrings the most touching of all
John Coffey played by the late Michael
Clarke Duncan and Paul Edgecomb played
by Tom Hanks who form an unusual
alliance at Cold Mountain penitentiary
where John is awaiting execution for a
crime he didn't commit
while the Green Mile has plenty of
emotional moments what in particular
gets the tears flowing every time even
though he's an innocent man John
confides in Paul that he wants to die
because the world is too cruel a place
for him to live moments before John is
killed Paul steps forward to shake his
hand
a subtle reminder that their bond was
true and a thank-you for sending him
onward the imitation game this
historical drama brings light to one of
Britain's most brilliant minds alan
turing the mathematician who became
famous for his efforts to crack the code
on the german enigma machines during
World War two despite his achievements
Turing was subject to extreme ridicule
by the United Kingdom's legal system
following the discovery that he was in a
same-sex relationship with a young man
the imitation game depicts this
arresting account of discrimination very
well but the tipping point comes near
the end facing the risk of losing his
latest machine which he named
Christopher after a boy he fell in love
with in school
Turing breaks down to one of the most
emotional on-screen performances in
recent years Toy Story 3 Pixar has a
particular way of pulling at your
emotions but there was something
uniquely devastating about 2010's Toy
Story 3 released 11 years after the
second installment Toy Story 3 had no
shortage of hilarious moments and
tongue-in-cheek references and it also
came with a plotline that drove a nail
straight into its audience's heart the
gang of toys don't belong to Andy
anymore a circumstance that leaves their
fates hanging by a thread during the
climax of the film the whole bunch end
up in an incinerator after an escape
plan goes wrong of course watching
characters you were first introduced to
when you were just a kid and danger is
difficult enough but the moment the crew
realizes that they're going to die and
decide to link up hands so they can face
their fate together is
next-level cinematic torture you had to
have eyes of steel to make it through
that scene without a few tears the
neverending story the 1984 film the
neverending story bills itself as an
epic fantasy but it could also be called
a psychological roller coaster because
that's exactly what audiences experience
when they witness a tre use horse
artex sink into the swamps of sadness
forever when the boy and horse pair are
trekking through the swamps our Tech's
get stuck in the mud and his two
downtrodden carry on so he slowly sinks
to his tragic fate and the camera
doesn't cut away guaranteeing no one
will step away dry-eyed not even a luck
dragon can make up for this kind of blow
to your emotions Good Will Hunting the
late Robin Williams oscar-winning
performance as Professor Shawn Maguire
in the 1997 drama Good Will Hunting is
one of his finest as the Academy can
clearly tell you and a lot of that comes
down to one Scene Matt Damon's Will
Hunting is speaking to Shawn about being
abused by his foster father and the
moment spirals into a stunning
breakthrough grounded in a single
sentence that sits sincere amongst a
film that's littered with sarcastic
one-liners thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]
you